This is the Chris Abraham show.
Hey there.
This is the Chris Abraham show
season 20.
Sorry, Season 5, 5 episode 21.
Bends Daewoo know that day.
What is what else?
Is it?
Fun.
See, I knew in Swansea is it on
and Swansea.
I don't know.
Anyway, You are probably being
completely distracted by the
sound of diesel trucks and the
sound of a waterfall.
It's really funny.
I feel like the trucks and the
construction trucks are just
moving closer to where I'm
trying to record, but I love
this little area and I just got
myself a huge espresso and two
bottles, the both de do do both
a do.
Is it good boat a dual?
Oh or is it just a boat a dough
shape, huh?
Anyway, today is just a really
casual one.
I'm not talking about all the
world's issues I'm talking
about, my weight loss journey
and a bunch of other little
stories based on what it's like
being a Completely obese, man
with, I guess.
Premature gray.
Premature, white hair black
don't crack.
But white do crack.
Is this white crack?
And there's another garbage
truck.
Another diesel garbage truck.
This is so much fun.
Hopefully they'll make the whole
thing run and make a bunch of
noise so we can listen to it.
It's going to be an ASMR.
Rather than a podcast.
So happy, belated heed to my
Islamic Muslim brothers and
sisters.
I do believe that yesterday was
Yesterday was Eid adha, Eid
al-adha.
And so, I live, people are
wondering why I live in this
neighborhood and why I live in
the building.
I live in, but when I was going
to check my mail yesterday at
the elevator was this like two,
beautiful, Muslim, families, all
dressed to the nines, so cute.
So, Able even a little girl.
So adorable had a leopard, print
backpack.
And one of the ladies and her
hijab had like a matching
leopard print vest, and
everybody had on their shiny
sparkly like awesome, crisply
pretty, strappy sandal shoes on
because that's how Muslim, women
Rock.
The fashion is toes shoes, nails
and and and eyebrows.
I think I think they Rock
eyebrows.
I've never seen a Muslim woman
who doesn't Rock eyebrows
anyway.
They were on their way out and I
wish them happy Eid and they
their let their faces light lit
up because like I really feel
like there's a complete divided
in America.
And I wished everybody yesterday
who I knew was Islamic or Muslim
and their faces lit up because
that was a celebratory day for
them.
I don't know what Eid al-adha
is, so I will try to include
that in the notes.
But I mean, Mark called me and
he always mocks me for living
here.
But I told him, I mean, what
other place in the country, it's
so rare.
Outside of maybe badly nor Patty
or longer.
I mean, I never even had this
experience when I lived in, d.c.
proper.
But every day I say, you know,
You know, hola que tal Todo,
bien Todo.
Bien I say bonjour.
Come on Telugu, or come over?
Come over to or I say.
How's it howdy?
How you doing?
Good morning.
Good afternoon.
I say assalamualaikum every day
and I still don't quite have
down.
Is it alaikum?
Salaam is it walaikum a'salam
when you say and peace be upon
you too?
Is it a ruse?
Allah Moosa, alaikum as-salaam,
alaikum as-salaam alaikum.
A salaam salaam has Salam
alaykum assalamu alaikum, o
allaikum assalaam I think is the
response.
So that's pretty awesome man.
Like what a great life, right?
Like I don't want all y'all to
move into 60 South Arlington and
it's kind of like a bespoke Sue.
I would say they're not
everybody gets it or enjoys it
or appreciates it.
It can feel a little bit like
you know, kind of it could feel
like a shithole it could feel
You know feels like the 70s
here.
I keep on saying that it's stuck
in the 80s but honestly this
neighborhood reminds me of when
I used to visit my I forgot the
neighborhood but my grandma and
grandpa lived in a part of
Northern New Jersey across the
bridge from where Where that,
you know, Northern New Jersey,
Main Campus of like, whatever
that universities called, and
like, it felt scruffy.
And there wasn't like, it wasn't
like, strip malls.
It was legit low block stores
store fronts.
This is all about the low block
storefront, right?
No big.
Parking lot in front.
It really is a different age and
everybody talks about how it's
going to change, you know,
there's some there's a few
executive Apartments kelp and
I'm drinking coffee from
Starbucks and I go to a giant
and I've got a Giant Pharmacy, a
CVS Pharmacy.
In a Walgreens, all within
walking distance.
I've got three cap days to go to
two of which I like one of,
which I'm sorry ruff.
Sonic.
I just like don't like your
coffee shop.
You know, that really
down-to-earth anyway back to
that.
So the story starts when I am
carrying around I bought a Chuck
Berry slick version of the
goruck gr1 26 liter which I'm
realizing that Now isn't really
that built, it's not over built
for schlepping, but I bought it
anyway because I like the color.
I like the coyote brown and if
I'd known how skanky and dirty
it gets, I would have just
gotten black but I like it.
I mean I just need to take a
brush and some diluted
dishwashing detergent and it'll
be good A little bit of Donald.
Do you?
But then, I had its cars updated
with Molly on the shoulder
strap.
So I could have a chest strap,
sternum strap, and then I had
cinching two pairs of cinching
straps, put in and all this
other stuff.
And so now it's a rucking bag
and In order to.
So I've been carrying around
around 12 kilograms, Without a
plate and then I'm like, you
know what, I want to carry as
much weight as I've lost.
So I wimped out and I should
have gotten a 30-pound plate,
but I got the 20 pound plate so
I put a 20 pound plate in and
now my bag is like 43 pounds.
The last time I weighed it
between 43 and 45 pounds, which
is around 20 kg and I wear that
everywhere.
I wear that everywhere the 20
pound plate.
It's all of my tech gear.
It's my super old x 220 Lenovo.
Another garbage truck with a
with a, with a base, a docking
base.
So it's like all the heavy in
the world and so, I just left it
around.
Now, it's also got a little bag
with my homemade, do it yourself
orange doubled paracord cable,
handle cable machine, handle
suspension trainer anyway, so
I'm walking home and the woman
next Or is apparently 83 she's
pretty spry, she's very Lively.
There is a, I don't know, 30 40
year old Driver.
He, he works.
He has his own gives his own
Suburban or whatever, like black
car and it is black car services
and he his family lives in the
building and his sister looks
identical to him.
But he's such a mensch that he
goes up and checks on her almost
every day.
And I don't I don't need another
Old lady looking after me in my
life right now, still suffering
PTSD from my mom.
So I don't really interact with
her, but I got the, the I got
the data, which is, I am
successful.
I've spent the last year and
I've told this to Mark.
I've spent the last year trying
to make myself as old and
invisible as humanly possible.
And at 350, like, You know, my
buddy, Keith even said it looked
like I was pushing for bills at
some point.
And like, nobody can believe.
I'm quote, only 53 for me, I'm
like, holy shit.
I'm 53 for everybody else.
It's like, we thought you were
60.
We thought you were 65.
We thought you were retired.
We thought you were 70.
So apparently, my success has
been too good and my response to
that is always the more
invisible.
I am the better, the more nobody
casts a sweet.
I At me the better, the more,
I'm Grandpa and not boyfriend,
the more I'm Grandpa material
and not boyfriend material.
The moment I've moved past that
creepy middle-aged where your
creepy uncle and I'm more safely
and invisible.
Granddad the better but that
happened with the guy on Uber
like he's this handsome black
guy in his 50s and I joked with
him when he told me, he thought
I was 65.
I told him that's not fair
black, don't crack and I feel
like the CPAP machine has really
aged my face because like I'm
literally wearing this thing
crunching, my face to keep a
seal with straps on my head, and
my face.
And this like breathing
apparatus, just look at, look at
the recent photos of Joe Biden
as they're trying to make a
mountain out of a molehill known
as his CPAP machine and look at
the strap marks.
At his face.
Like, there's no denying that at
least, you know, for a few hours
after you stop using it.
Your face is like Is like, you
know that fresh for women and
men who sleep with their face
down when they wake up from a
nap and they've got completely
that she'd face kind of like
that.
So, yeah, so I'm doing it.
I am doing it and the longest
torch long and short story about
this is that the reason why I'm
carrying around this 43 pounds,
Ruk everywhere.
I go, when I'm not biking, when
I'm not sitting when I'm not
podcasting.
And when I'm not at the cafe,
when I'm not at the library, or
when I'm not meeting friends,
I'm not going to schlep a 43.
Pound Rock what?
I'm just going to meet friends
or going to a movie theater or
whatever.
When I'm slipping back and
forth, medical Bulow do Meto
blue do.
Then I I carried The Rock.
And the reason is is because I
want to prove.
It's not about dude, you're
going to kill your dooney's,
dude, you're going to hurt your
back.
I felt fragile since I died in
2017.
Since I had the heart failure
since I died since I attained.
Let's say 350, 400 pounds since
I had edema in my in my legs
since I had afib since I had
panic attacks, I felt so
fragile.
I felt 75 years.
Sold.
I had an old man's disease.
Afib is an old man's disease and
caring effortlessly, the 43
Sunnah, be 53 pound rucksack.
Everywhere I go is a renewal of
vows its renewal of vows to
myself.
It's like a self marriage.
It's like a commitment to a
future.
It's like a commitment that I'm
just not sputtering until
someone smells.
Something awful from my
apartment in calls, you know,
calls the fire brigade.
So my recommitment to myself and
my recommitment to my goals and
my recommitment to a long
healthy life and even my
recommitment to say to us, daily
practice of slow, jogging is
based on how comfortable I feel.
Slipping around a pack that one
would say is only the foolish
Venture of a much younger man.
So that's my pledge.
My pledge is even though it
sounds stupid, and it is stupid.
Maybe I'm being as careful as
possible.
You big diesel truck.
What do you even doing on this
street?
This is a freakin Road Columbia,
Pike.
It's a pike.
I guess.
Big Pepsi truck is you pass
during my podcast.
Big diesel city bus with optimal
hell all good health plan you
can count on going by a big
F-350 pickup going by you go
girls you go girls three snaps,
three snaps.
Anyway, I guess this is the end
of pride month, tomorrow's the
30th in sha Allah and also yeah.
Like I don't know if I ever
mentioned this probably not but
I really had a hard fall when I
was wearing big ass Hoka on a
own, a bond eyes and I was
walking walking walking and I
freaking went down and rolled
Old and went down hard and it
like bruised.
My entire sympathetic chain to
the point where it had no
sympathy.
And I, you know, my ankles swell
swole swelled and it sucks.
So now that I've actually added
a 20 pound cast, iron plate into
my bag.
I don't care about my.
My laptop getting damaged
because I have three other.
Like it identical, just let to
others three.
Others just like it.
And they're about, you know, two
hundred dollars on eBay still.
But but what bothers me is, I
don't want to roll my ankle and
then go down in like injure
myself under a plate or under a
43 pound bag.
So, Walgreens truck, Walgreens
diesel, truck.
So I'm wearing no bull my Noble
booties.
My no goal weight, lifting
That I bought used off of eBay
their size 14, apparently, I
need size, 14 and Noble.
Apparently, if you get Noble
shoes, they run a little little
small and they're weightlifting
shoes.
So there's virtually there zero
drop.
They might be called, they might
be called barefoot shoes if they
were a little bit more flexible
but They're definitely more
along the lines of if you own
original, Chuck Taylors, or
original Vans, or other type of
weightlifting, casual shoes, and
I love them very much.
So I'm wearing those instead and
on the days that I am really
going for long walks, I'm going
to just wear like a Hill People
Gear chest rig and a 3-liter
bladder on my back.
So I'm not going to carry A43
pound bag on my long rocks,
that's just stupid.
That that's just stupid.
Only when I do my local, my
local trips, you know, from my
apartment, to the library, to
the cafe, to the Penrose Park,
to Walter Reed community park
and so forth.
That's when I'm going to carry
it.
Oh, and there's an addition of
my bag.
I might have told you that I've
been carrying hey city bus.
I might have told you city bus
and second city bus.
My beloved Route 16 buses and my
beloved bus drivers.
Oh, don't forget if you take a
city bus or any bus always say
thank you to your bus driver.
I feel like they treat buses
like they're run by robots but
they're not and bus drivers
respond very well even from the
dorky white guy who says hello
sir.
I hope you're doing well and
have a good.
Sir, thanks for the ride but I'm
that guy I am.
That guy I would do it to the
Metro Riders.
The Metro drivers if I could but
that's not really a thing.
Always be generous, always be
grateful, always wave at people
letting you through.
Always be very generous with
people who are driving.
They could kill you always be
nice to drivers cuz they have a
death vehicle, a death dick,
always be nice.
Two drivers because they're
driving a deathmobile that could
kill you without even doing any
damage to their vehicle, their
car, their trucks, their bus,
their truck, their car, their
bust.
Oh my alright.
So I was carrying around a TRX
strap and a set of jump rope
that don't have any rope on
them, just rubber balls at the
end and I realize that I'm not
quite up to up to You fake jump
rope yet so I downgraded a
little pouch.
I carry things on to the gr one
pouch that Ruckus goruck makes
its sexy little coyote brown one
to match my sexy, hot Barry bag,
you garbage truck going by and I
decided to come up with my own
suspension strap workout tool.
So I went onto Amazon Prime and
I bought a, I bought
high-strength orange paracord.
So instead of like 300 pounds,
this is our 500 pounds or 42
pounds.
This is a 700-pound, right?
Orange California, California.
you know the California Street
Works Orange, you know the color
the safety orange for for you
Hunters out there and then I
asked and my buddy my business
partner buddy and one of my
closest friends Dan Krueger told
me okay well baby, you know,
make it 30 feet So, I decided,
well, what am I going to do,
like, at the end?
Like, so I started to look for
maybe just Titanium or aluminum
pipe, and then I Came Upon
aluminum, aluminum grips for at
the end of, you know, cable
machines.
So, so, they're two grips at the
each end of a cable machine.
This one on, On Amazon is so
good.
I really love them.
They are.
The brand is The brand is Brian
Fitness.
So I bought the ones with the
gray straps, and the silver
handles and they've got these
d-rings.
And then what I did is I got the
orange paracord.
And since I'm six foot three or
six foot four, I measured the
Paracord by extending my arms
three times which is I guess 6,
12, 18 feet.
Then I did it again so so
because I wanted to double it
up, right?
So that's what I did.
I I guess, right?
36 feet total 36 feet total
divided in half is Is, is 18
feet and so, what I did is, I
looked online to get a good like
way of meeting the two pieces at
the very end, so I found a
fisherman's knot, which I made
perfectly the first time.
Thank you, YouTube, and Google
images.
And then what before I made that
not, of course, I put the two
d-rings on there and then so
it's Over and then I made sure I
found the middle and then I made
then I every foot or so, maybe
every two feet every path.
M actually every every foot or
15 12 to 15 inches.
I put a knot in both.
So so the, so I Loop the two
handles into the giant 36-foot
Loop.
So it's doubled.
So it's only 18 feet and then I
made sure that I tied every 12
to 15 inches.
I made a simple knot so that the
entire thing wouldn't be moving
around or sliding around.
So essentially it is those two
cable handled met by 18 or so
feet of Orange.
Power cable paracord.
That's doubled over.
And so it should have
technically speaking enough test
is that the word enough breaks
train that my simple and stupid
TRX, exercises will be fine.
The one thing that I didn't
Implement that I bought was a
bunch of shrink-wrap tubing, you
know like shrink wrap rubber
tubing that they put on things
like Paracord pulls that are on
backpacks and stuff, but I'm not
going to.
I could cut the I could cut the,
I could cut the Paracord and
then put you know back into
fishermen fisherman's knots and
everything would be fine but I'm
just going to leave it the way
it is so I can get a real-world
test as to when I throw it over
tree limbs how long before the
Paracord phrasing breaks.
X.
And then, you know, paracord
sheep.
I'm not using then, I can decide
whether I want to go with Kevlar
cord, or if I want to go, I
don't want to go with with, with
rope.
This is fine.
Very light.
And then the next time before I,
you know, make all the knots and
everything else.
The next time I make one or if I
make a second one I will put
loads of I will put loads of
shrink Rubber tubing onto the
abrasion point but I won't know
what the abrasion points are
until I use it without the
tubing for now.
So it goes everywhere.
I go it's just really light.
I feel like the bag that
overbuilt bag is is way heavier
than the and the handles are
kind of heavy even there are
though their aluminium alloy
aluminum but Making their
perfect.
You know what they do?
They they spin beautifully.
You know, when you're doing
things like like flies and fall
over, xand reverse flies and and
things like that.
It's nice to have a real kind of
smooth transition as opposed to
one, that might be extremely
gritty or whatever.
So the lightness that I suffer
by not having like Titanium or
PVC handles directly connected
to paracord by doing some sort
of you know not triangle nod or
something like that.
I think is worthwhile just for
the fit and finish of this and
the knurled aluminium aluminum
handles, they feel good in the
hand.
So, That is worth that.
I also bought a bunch of
carabiners, but I'm using a
really cheap petzl.
What's called the carrot tool L
called a large carrot tool,
which is made out of basically
blown plastic.
It's only looks like a
carabiner.
I'm going to.
It says that it doesn't have any
value as a real Carabiner at
all.
So, we'll see if my If my
weight?
Using it as like I said, press
has pulled bicep tricep fall
overs flies T flies wife lies,
assisted squats.
Biceps triceps, all those
things.
Those are really easy.
Way to assisted kill t-they're
not.
This is not replacing, some sort
of hanging from the ceiling
gymnast, just gymnast where they
called are called not Loops
gymnast.
This is the way it's down.
They're not T-Rex has to be up
to be hung from and they're not
Circles, damn it.
What are they called?
I wish I could visualize it
would jog my memory.
Gymnast.
Hoops circles.
I don't know, you can tell me in
the comments or send me a dummy
message.
So that's me every day after I
finish working at the libraries,
I slept over to Walter Reed Park
at between six to eight pm
depending on how much work I
have at the library.
And when the library closes, if
the library closes at 5:00, I
will go over to Columbia.
I'll go over to commodious.
I'll go over to Walter Reed
community park at, you know,
5:15 5:30 or 5:00, because I'll
leave early.
So, as to not stress out the
Librarians, I also say, thank
you and hello, and goodbye to
them all the time, too.
So be nice to the people around
you, right?
They deserve love.
And you need to compensate for
every Karen or every, every,
every what is it, Carl?
What's the male form of a Karen
men and women who are Karen's or
Karen?
So, Since we live in a
gender-fluid world, you everyday
need to compensate for the fact
that someone suffered a Karen
and they need that.
They need that life-affirming,
love that you have to give to
them.
Look them in the eye, always
meet their eye and less you have
Unless you're on the Spectrum or
are complete introvert and that
is like the worst thing in the
world to you.
But if you meet someone in the
eye, and hold it for a second,
and show with your face, that
they're not just words that will
make up, that will improve their
day as much as a Karen destroys
their day.
And I guarantee you while you
might not be part of their
cocktail party cocktail day
Predator about complaining about
the person they met that Each
day you will build them up and I
think we need to build each
other up.
And telling me, I look 70 is
exactly what I want you to do,
but it still hurts my, my big
brother.
I don't know if you guys know
the fraternity system, but I I
joined a fraternity chartered
Fraternity in GW called Phi
Kappa.
PSI and my big brother.
The person whose job it was to
Mentor me.
We called love Be Love. them and
love the guy, he's such a like
He's he's awesome but like he's
the kind of guy who like ribs
you right.
Like he's that he's so much love
though.
Like I realize that, all that
ribbing was really just out of
so much love and the moment he
realizes that he hurts you.
He gives you like a big virtual
hug or a big real hug or loves
on you.
So love, he's always been like
that, but I would never ever try
to show weakness.
Like, he helped teach me the
Greek alphabet.
He helped teach me that his
History of Phi, Kappa, PSI, he
helps, you know, get me through
the whole thing.
And so we're still friends on on
Facebook and he's a made man.
Now, so all he does is travel
around and visit friends and
visit cities and goes to the
best.
Jewish delis in the world.
Love the guy, we've gotten
closer because of Facebook.
I really think like there was 20
years just after college, where
I just didn't do a very good job
at all of keeping up.
Up.
Anyway, my fraternity pledge
name was Zeus, right?
So first of all, that is the
best pledge name ever.
It's a Greek god, it's it's the
god of Greek god just like the
daddy of Greek gods.
Just like the god of gods and
they made a story up about how.
How how they were going to call
me Lord?
Because of Jack Lord, because of
growing up in Hawaii, but they
thought calling me Lord, was
going to be go to my head, so
they call me Zeus instead.
And every time he sees me
looking 75 years old he's like
we might need to revoke your
name, you're not looking very
Zeus, you're not looking very
Zeus so I should have become a
doctor, I should have gotten a
PhD and become dr.
Zeus anyway, so hopefully in the
next year, I'll become beautiful
enough to be to be to be Zeus
again.
So anyway that's that's my
stories for today.
Sorry I didn't carry water for
Putin today.
Sorry I didn't do any heterodox
things.
I'm sorry.
I didn't blame Ukraine for being
in a war sorry about all these
things but I love you anyway.
And if you're here for that kind
of conversation, I'm hoping that
the incredibly loud sound of all
that water at Penrose Square
Park.
The it's a kind of a plague.
Sounds like it's, it's, I guess
shell, or, or it's.
Anyway, it's flat stone.
Shall Stone flat stone.
And the water comes up from the
ground, from the, from the, from
the stone tiling.
And at a certain point of the
day, it becomes kid.
Kid world, write 1,000 little
kids, and in their swimwear,
come out here with moms but
they're not here yet because
they might be hiding inside.
Because it says, Is that the
weather quality is terrible and
I can't see very far.
So it looks like a foggy day but
this is Canadian Wildfire brand
fog in Arlington right now.
If you go to I don't know.
You go to some place, you go to
my Reddit profile.
I think you might see, I don't
know.
I don't know where I posted a
photo from my apartment.
You can go find it.
So yeah so maybe if all you One
is really kind of my heterodox
stuff about opt-in.
Eugenics, movement, sore, or the
are we?
The baddies concept of Western
imperialism.
Very literally stroke slow.
A slow-rolling or saying that
Germany actually won World War
Three because they fooled
everybody into the EU.
All these things you want to
hear that kind of heterodox con
hetero.
Ducks heterodox content, then
just hold on.
I'm sure another one will come
out.
Like I made an awful comments.
Saying there were new.
There was news to.
Okay, I'll give you one.
There was news yesterday about
how either a rocket.
Bomb a missile or a terrorist
act, blew up a pizza restaurant
in a town in Ukraine, killing
like a million moms and kids and
babies.
And I think that there's like 16
dead and 30 not 12 dead and 39
or 40 injured and my asshole
what an asshole it's answer was
why the like people stayed
inside for covid 42?
Two fucking years and you're in
the middle of a hot war and you
can't fucking stay home and not
go to a crowded pizza restaurant
for fuck sake.
And then I realized that that's
only what an asshole would say.
So I put the whole thing into
quotes More likely, it's
bullshit.
And just the result of a
propaganda machine because it
doesn't make any sense and I
love you and I'll talk to you
soon.
And please don't hate me too
much.
Because I don't know, at all.
What I'm talking about.
I am like the Leia, slowest,
Laius, layman in the lowest
lamest, Layman world.
I got a Fantasia Nest, am I
don't have a master's degree.
I started in political science
degree but got it, American
literature degree.
And And all my friends think I'm
that crazy uncle even though I
don't drink anymore so I'm not
drunk uncle.
So thank God for that.
Love you guys.
Come back soon.
Talk to you later.
Ciao.
Thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham show.
Make sure you subscribe.
So you don't miss any future
episodes until next time.